why don't they teach money in school i'm
sure you have a prediction or philosophy
on
on the reasoning behind that well that's
the story of rich dad poor dad
my poor dad was a hardcore socialist
they're good people don't get me wrong
you know they think the way you help
people is you give
give them money you know give a man a
fish and they become a welfare dependent
and a capitalist believes in teaching
people to fish
and i would say 98
of all school teachers are hardcore
marxist i grew up with them
they're good people but they don't know
how to make money
i mean when i don't know if you went you
know the school i went to
every school teacher was broke
true yes i was a substitute teacher
before i got into the financial world
and i said i can't do this anymore i
make 100 bucks a day
i'm uh this doesn't work out so i'm with
you on that mr kasiak
yeah so i'd rather teach people to fish
and socialists like bonnie and all those
guys they're going to destroy the whole
economy
you know when they cancel the pipeline
and whatever that whatever that thing
was
he's doing pipeline he's doing an
exercise
uh unemployment you know they're gonna
they're gonna wipe out exxon i think
exxon and mobile are gonna merge or
something like this
exxon and chevron are tired and talks
about potentially murder
you know i was a tanker officer for them
for a few years
wow and i can fly i learned nothing
about money
thank you for watching this short clip
if you want to see the full episode
check it out right here and if you have
not subscribed to valuetainment
click right here